Nightmare. You're a dog
person, not a cat person.
I'm just saying I would like a
hairless cat. Oh, like a sphinx.
I think they're cool. This shit
in a box in your house. Perfect.
So do I piss your house? I'm going to
change my toilet to be Roman. Fuck you.
I'm going to shit in a box.
Yeah, they shit in a box.
But that's a great thing to grow.
Sometimes my dog's crap on the carpet
with their, you know, irritable.
But cats are weird, man. Cats. I
don't know if you can trust a cat.
You try some cats. You have a couple of
cats, don't you? You've got a fucking zoo.
I'm so jealous. I want to come over and
just pet everything in your house. Oh,
my dog's died recently. Oh, I'm sorry. I
guess it was probably almost a year now.
It was Marshall Sad.
He didn't understand what was going on.
He looks like he's just pure joy and
happy all the time. He's the happiest.
He's so he brings me joy.
I just started following him on Instagram.
He's so happy. Follow your dog on
Instagram. He's my buddy. He's, he's,
it's so weird. Like you can see you
guys have a straight bond. Let's see.
So affectionate. Do you run him off leash
in the morning when you go? Oh yeah.
Yeah. No tickets. You know, he's been, um,
he's got tick medication that he's taking,
but we have caught him with a couple of
ticks home without all that luxurious
hair. Those ticks or Pi like match. He,
he loves it though.
He never seen anything in is pure joy
as that dog is like running through the
canyons. He just loves it. He's so happy.
So how do you keep him so clean? I mean,
I know you got that.
Like Joe Rogan experience money,
but he is luxurious cold water.
Well all it takes everyone
else to hear clones up water.
And I've seen these mangled beasts,
they really don't.
And they wonder why they
lash out. Marshall's not
like for cats. When you die,
cattle start eating your face and like
16 hours dogs wait about a week. Yeah,
they probably don't even wait that
long dog to wait about a week.
They love you a little bit more.
They won't eat you right away.
I don't even know if
Marshall would eat you.
I think you'd wait even know what you
were probably wouldn't understand it.
He would just keep throwing balls at you.
Just rolling them over to you,
which is wine. My woke me up
yesterday was fucking really annoying.
Whining.
You just decides to get up.